he's not even eating
oh
yeah he's got some good ground speed
no
hurry now oh
my God not just as like a side note it's
nice to see what it looks like on a
darker skin so you know what is going to
happen to other people
he's like wait what
my blood
is medicine
I just feel like she's just comforting
yeah she doesn't want to be scared but
it's like yeah he's younger than you oh
he doesn't want her to hurt herself oh
why do they always do the hand
where else are you gonna do your foot
anyway
at least he can fight it in her
hmm
my sweet angel
[Music]
oh my baby
oh
at least I gave him a burial he's just
like gone
you can't do anything about a girl
[Music]
don't read it as private
um
welcome back to New rockstars The Last
of Us episode 5 titled endure and
survive is here early and so are we oh
baby a show where giant Mushroom Men
kill Nazis have previously killed
different Nazis and somehow they're all
villains the government's all Nazis I
don't think the bloat is a villain oh
this is the break room Our Daily Show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news that you need to know and today
we're talking about The Last of Us
episode five so stay out of the sewers
and open your last can of beans as we
dive in you know it's a sad true fact I
finished my last can of beans last night
how many fried beans you better get more
beans maybe I'm Jessica Clemens and with
me today is Brandon Barrick oh hello
happy to be here
oh that's very sweet you know you know
my favorite sign is in ASL restaurant
because it's a little shrimp floating
back oh I noticed I think he would like
this one for noisy
it's the movement of uh floating
background swimming backwards it makes
sure it because when it was time you're
being too noisy he kind of went like
this or like this I don't know well the
actor is actually deaf yeah so much I
love all that representation they've had
in so many things in the last couple
years it's been great uh we're so
excited to talk about this episode but
first we want to tell you that our merch
Partners at nerd Riot have recently
released a brand new shirt inspired by
The Last of Us called Lost in the
darkness here it is
oh baby look for the light you know you
can pick up this awesome shirt at nerd
riot.shop where you will also find tons
of great merch featuring new rock stars
and other nerdy fandoms support the
channel and rock some great merch at
nerd riot.shop also look at this jacket
am I sweating on camera it's because of
this nice warm jacket I know it's
probably because of the three layers of
the three layers it looks cool oh
goodness
all good actors wear three layers at
least uh this is the same jacket that
Joel wears on the Last of Us not the
exact same one but you know what I mean
the jackets from huckberry uh the
costume designers that the last of us
use a flint and Tinder wax canvas
trucker jacket from huckberry for Joel's
iconic look so you can pick one up for
yourself if you want to click the link
in the video's description to buy your
own and that also helps support The Last
of Us coverage here at new rock stars uh
so rock it out uh at your next con it's
con season baby walk it out with your
jacket out also yeah I think it's really
good for Pins
yeah if you're a pin Trader at Disney
Parks hit me up for a convention for
Last of Us now as a reminder the first
part of this episode will be spoiler
free we'll just be talking about what
you saw in the episode no game stuff
none of that other stuff we recommend if
you haven't played the games to avoid
reading the comments and if you're in
the comments don't spoil stuff uh just
just be nice to everybody there are a
few foreshadowing moments in this
episode for folks that have played the
game so we'll be leaving those out of
the episode recap and covering them at
the end of the show but for now let's
get into our spoiler free section of the
last of us and talk about episode five
this episode opens with a oh so long and
torturous flashback to the fall of fedra
which we find was only 10 days ago in
Kansas City which I was surprised to see
that yeah I guess makes a lot of sense
that Henry and Sam have only been on the
run for like 10 days yeah they still got
that like pent-up energy kind of yeah
they got that fresh we're just starting
camping uh this this to me was some of
the darkest stuff I've seen on
television in a long time oh yeah the
guy that was being dragged with knives
in him a man being strung up shot in the
head and then all of that you know this
reminds of the previous episode when uh
Ali was like wondering like who's out
there is it Federal is it Raiders and he
was like just people yeah people man and
I think we mentioned last time in in the
games I don't feel like this is really a
spoiler they have on the front of the
truck a guy with his legs cut off like a
dead guy just like to show how Savage
they are and this helped demonstrate the
Savages
this Federal was Savage okay these were
bad people that needed to be taken down
but in a Time in the World when we all
should be coming together and helping
each other we're only more dangerous and
more violent it's very scary
uh so violence begets violence as the
resistance brutally kills and hangs
Federal soldiers in informants uh that
was very dark Henry and Sam are on the
Run ducking between buildings looking
for a safe place to bed down while
Kathleen tells a group of federal
informants that they'll all be tried but
you know they're all guilty so that's
how that will go uh but first she needs
the location of Henry one of the
Informer spills the beans and Kathleen
tells Perry to Kill Them All and when
he's done burn the bodies it's faster
she's efficient I guess that's what
we're to look at it even Perry was like
oh we're gonna have We're not gonna have
a trial and she's like no we're not
gonna have a trial Perry
uh this is probably the smoldering pile
of bodies that Joel and Ellie passed as
they drove past the town on the last
episode of very dark uh one quick note
on Perry that we missed last week he's
being played by Jeffrey Pierce who
played Tommy in the game if you played
the games you might recognize that voice
producer John takes full responsibility
for missing that detail and we are not
cool
uh Henry and Sam make it to a safe house
with Dr Edelstein this was the doctor
that Kathleen will later kill that we
saw killed in the previous episode some
time jumping going on here and we
learned that Sam is deaf Henry proposes
they escape through the tunnels and
Edelstein says might as well kill
yourself right here Jesus Edelstein no
spoilers please no spoilers I I at first
I didn't know if if they were gonna make
Sam deaf because I was like you know
what that's actually really smart to
learn some sign language in a poster
podcast right right I thought yeah maybe
they're just being quiet that was the
leak that came out actually a long long
time ago that Sam was going to be a deaf
character they were looking for a black
man death between ages 8 to 14 and I
guess this 18 or this eight-year-old
really took a great job great job um cut
to 10 days later and Sam and Henry are
out of food realizing that edelston
isn't coming back they have to go out
and find food on their own Henry gives
Sam his superhero alter ego and as they
leave Henry watches Joel absolutely murk
some of Kathleen's men which we saw
earlier and I wonder how this dude could
be helpful we all Wonder we all wonder I
would just like to say again something
that bill pointed out Resource
Management okay it could be wasting pain
on the face all right also what's up
that's an outdoor pen kid
that's not good for them and you know
what he didn't wash it off before going
to bed and I was like that's terrible
it's gonna break out he's an
eight-year-old black boy they have
beautiful skin are you guys out of your
mind I'm just concerned about Resource
Management look at the paint what are
they gonna do so who's gonna paint the
steps Henry and Sam hold up Joel and
Ellie but this time we know those guns
aren't loaded at all Henry is clearly
not great at this but gets what he wants
I do love Ellie telling Henry that Joel
has an voice of the best of us
so this was written by John because John
has an I mean that that
giant producer John does have an
uh I did love that I mean Joel is so
great in this sequence Pedro Pascal and
limbo when he's like you ate we didn't
kill each other let's call this a win I
love when Henry was like what that's not
that doesn't sound like yeah yeah
he's like I'm okay
so everything's oh good it's great
emphasize the great Henry tells Joel
that he can get them out of the city
Joel has heard that the Kansas City is
one of the worst in the nation in a
surprise it's Fallen Henry says he's
never killed anyone before while Ellie
and Sam Bond over the pun book I do like
that that little hint that like yeah
word about how bad cities are gets out I
mean we saw that in the first episode
with the radios and we've heard of tales
of what's going on out there but like
Kansas City was so bad other accusers
were like uh it sucks here in Boston but
at least we're not in Canada I feel like
that's the most you can do is just Word
of Mouth it right uh Henry explains that
his plan involves using the tunnels
under the city to make an escape the
catch fedra drove the infected
underground years ago and baby he's very
smart I mean I did once they said that
well it was it was a smart move by fedra
it didn't pay off in the end
but it was a smart move because I didn't
even notice that until they mentioned
that we didn't see like infected stuff
throughout the city ever and I was like
oh it makes sense but then you just
think long and maybe that's Federal this
is a very Federal idea mine said uh long
term it's gonna cave in just the ground
no one's keeping up with it so it's for
maintenance that's tomorrow's problem
Henry claims that it's empty but boy
howdy we saw the ground shake last
episode and what came out of it uh in
this one we also hear our first mention
of the word clicker oh in Universe baby
they use the terms we used in the game
he was like you saw clicker and survive
see I knew you were good
and the tunnels everything looks fine
and Henry declares the plan is good they
find the remnants of a community with a
daycare started by a man named ish and
this is really sweet the name is a
reference to isherwood Williams the
protagonist from the novel Earth abides
set in a post-apocalyptic landscape who
also starts a community of pandemic
survivors this is a small detail carried
over from the game oh absolutely
delicious I did love like finding that
painted room and you're like what how
did this happen and like Henry being or
Sam being so excited to go into Henry
being like yeah we found it we thought
Joe's like no stop what are you doing he
also didn't check behind the door it's
all done and I was like just look behind
the door
there's just no camera to the left
that's the problem they did frame that
like something was behind the door it
was very scary uh Ellie finds her first
issue of savage Starlight this is a
comic from the game it was great to see
it endurance survive is the title or is
like the slogan of this uh and it was
right last week that we did get our
first look at these episodes
congratulations give me my camera
oh she dabbed on us she's turning she's
turning she's infected uh she's infected
with dab Henry tells Joel while he why
he ratted out on the resistance uh
Kathleen's brother Michael was in his
word a man he'd follow anywhere but Sam
got leukemia and needed medication from
fedra something we heard Kathleen saying
to the informants like you did this for
medicine and apples uh so he gave
Michael the leader of this resistance
Kathleen's brother uh he gave him up to
fedra Henry labels himself as a bad guy
and really seems to hate himself for the
things he's had to do for his family to
endure and survive Henry tells Joel he
might not be her father
she was someone's God damn it Henry you
make me cry anymore in this episode and
you will they're really good at it that
was like a heavy heavy line I love
seeing these two characters come
together because they really judged each
other at first you know Joel assuming
that this like you know guy is like a
killer in Kansas City or something he's
like I've never killed anyone I'm just
trying to take care of my my deaf
brother like we're just trying to do our
best here yeah I also wonder do you
think that uh Henry like using the
terminology of bad guy I wonder if that
sort of you know Sam's uh not obsessed
but you know hooked on the superhero and
stuff and the comics of good versus evil
so I think the term using the term like
bad guy really I felt connected
especially with like another adult like
saying like yeah I'm a bad guy I'm a bad
guy yeah Perry finds Kathleen and her
child at home we hear more about Michael
from Kathleen's point of view and it
does paint a picture of a wonderful man
who took care of the people he loves and
we get a better understanding of why
Kathleen is so motivated by her grief
even though Michael told her to forgive
in prison now that they're out of the
tunnels the group of four make their way
through the residential suburbs of
Kansas City a sniper down the street
takes aim at them who we later learn is
working with Kathleen Joel makes his way
to the sniper and kills him just as we
learn the resistance is making their way
there now that's a great reveal I love
that review I loved it oh at first I was
like if there's no radio is this man
just working by himself
I've been here 85 years
too like he's a terrible shot don't
worry it's dark
he wasn't that bad but he didn't hit it
when he was running I was like Kim you
are one like second behind him every
single time go ahead of him I don't know
how to hunt people still takes out one
of the armored vehicle drivers who who
cares into a nearby house the vehicle
explodes and falls into a sinkhole as
the resistance swarms Henry salmonella a
horde of infected reverse through that
sinkhole including our first bloater
they were living underground after all
they were still there that when when it
went in the tunnel first off good timing
for you guys congratulations
got executed publicly until now you guys
all kind of did but anyways when it
started going in there I was like
earthquake I was like earthquake and
then when I was like oh there's like I
was screaming oh baby now do you think
that there were a lot of infected that
burst out of there do you think that a
good percentage of those were the people
who were living in the tunnels the
community that was living I think they
were definitely swarmed up by that we'll
we'll touch on that here because all
hell breaks loose and Joel takes out
clickers left and right like it's Saving
Private Ryan and he's up in The Sniper
Tower Capac
trying to keep his friends safe mainly
just Ellie I think he's mostly concerned
about it yeah Sam and Henry we're
getting attacked Ellie narrowly escapes
an infected girl that probably came from
that same underground Community This
Little Child in Blue's Clues pajamas uh
doing a freaky little Megan style bend
over into the car when she I was so
scared and then when she did the back I
went oh real quick was that a a small
framed adult actress or was that a child
they put that makeup that was a child
they put that makeup on and they were
like we need a gymnast child a gymnast
child I think she's the same age as Sam
we should look this up afterwards
because you think it was a child yeah
I've done a couple of like monster calls
for for TV and is that when you call
children and pretend to be a monster
exactly why no it's like auditions where
they want you to show like your rain oh
like how you can like move yeah they
talked about in the after Show podcast
for this on HBO that's so great listen
to it please uh when they were the
clickers in the first episode they found
these like contortionist dancer movement
people who like I played the game and
like really knew how to do the movements
uh love it love it
um
hey yeah Kathleen however is not so
lucky and Perry gets his head torn off
by a bloater and it's great to point out
that uh Kathleen was the one saying kids
die every day who kills her thank you
thank you best ones for the kids
Kathleen Henry Sam Ellie and Joel
escaped to a nearby Motel Henry again
confesses that he's a monster for what
he's had to do Joe's I love this moment
where Joel's like hey I know I judge you
for being a rat but like if this is why
you were being a rat I get it because I
would do the same thing Sam asked Ellie
how she's able to be so brave and Ellie
confesses that she's afraid of ending up
alone Sam shows Ellie that he's been
bitten and Ellie tries to heal him with
her immune blood with her immune blood
in the morning Sam's turn and attacks
Ellie and it's
I thought we had another episode I
thought we had another episode Henry has
to shoot Sam and after doing what he did
to Michael and now Sam he turns the gun
on himself yeah it doesn't wait very
long either I mean yeah it's your
brother everything yeah this is your
only reason to survive what else do you
have to live for Joel and Ellie Berry
salmon Henry and Ellie lives on I'm
sorry note on Sam's grave the pair
continued heading to Wyoming on foot ah
just heavy stuff what do you call just
an aside what do you call that thing I
had one when I was a child but I forgot
imagine magic It's gotta be magic this
one's like a Woody Woodpecker one I
noticed it had like a faded way we had
one growing up all the time
did you know the answer because it was
like chalk on the bottom or something I
did love with that moment too of Ally
still in the room with Sam which like
God bless him for staying in that room
all night staying awake even though she
did fall asleep uh she's able to walk up
to Sam because even infected like Sam
still can't like hear her coming you
know what I mean he's still deaf like
the fungus doesn't fix that we saw how
the fungus made like the old weren't
able to like move and stuff again but
the fungus can't like make it clear
again just just so intense uh so as we
dive into this episode my first question
for both of you is do you think Ellie
actually thought she could save Sam with
her blood well she's just being like
hopeful and trying to comfort him in
this moment because he didn't know
anything about her blood like she
decides to show it is she just trying to
like she knows this is not gonna work
and she's just doing it to keep him calm
or do you think like I think she had a
hope I think she was hopeful because
it's like no one's maybe no one's tried
it and that was actually a good example
of us knowing that no one has cut her
open yet but I think she uh genuinely
was like okay I know my blood is a
medicine but we haven't tried this yet
maybe I can try I don't think she was
just doing it to make him feel better I
think she was like hopeful that it might
have that might actually work yeah I
agree no I agree with that I think that
right now or I feel like a up until now
Ellie has sort of been the embodiment of
Hope innocence in this dark situation
um a ready to kill infected Innocents
but an innocence nonetheless
um and I think she thought that this
would work otherwise I don't think she
would have like fallen asleep beside him
like he's trying to yeah yeah but yeah
yeah maybe she accidentally fell asleep
but I think
yeah I don't think she thought he was
going to turn I thought or at least I
think she had a lot of hope that he
wouldn't it was worth a shot yeah is it
possible Marlene ever tried this with
her I like to think that Marlene we had
her for a few days it was like 10 days I
forget the exact amount of time I think
she had said like it's been 10 days I
haven't turned or whatever uh I would
think maybe Marley when she's doing her
test is like count to ten show us your
hand if they tried like let's get a
little bit of her blood and take it over
to an infected and see if we could do I
don't know if they've captured and
infected I could see that happening but
her not disclosing that to her that it
worked or it didn't work if you're
applying the scientific method to this
child with an immunity that you found
let's just try the first test we can say
I'm no doctor take a little blood makes
a little another Blood single Bingo
spoon I mean that costs extra
um I guess it depends on who is the
medical professional with Marlene
because I'm like if it dies on hand of
oxygen what are you doing getting blood
out into just if they had the medical
need or the medical stuff there at the
where the fireflies were they tried a
little blood but once you just like drop
it on the ground
if you did a complete transfusion I
don't know if you moved all of her blood
out into a new body I pulled it all out
let's try it out let's try it out but
yeah I'm sure I think when she was in
captivity they probably did a lot more
tests than we saw but I don't think she
would have been disclosed any of that I
would have been if it had worked I would
have been like come on that would have
been too easy for me this isn't this
isn't me at all as a way out but I was
like I I started when I watch shows like
this and I especially when it's a child
that's about to get killed I look up the
actor make sure they're okay but they
didn't actually kill them on saying well
I just want to make sure they're having
a help a healthy life oh okay because
I'm just like after seeing them play
this sad sad role I'm like yeah
he's like the first hot deaf like
student hockey player at his school and
it's a big thing in his hometown but
um I started being like oh he was also
he knows what death is unfortunately and
all these things because he was born
during the pandemic so I was like if
Ellie is immune how many other kids that
were born into to this or could possibly
be immune from different ways yeah I was
like
this but I was like hopeful that
yeah very sad maybe 10 minutes there
probably are other people but yeah how
will we find them you have to get bit to
find out that's not the best test uh um
yeah you are right too that he's not
he's very accustomed to death because
he's the one that asks right away like
hey is that too dead is Edelstein dead
and like seeing his brother be like
probably yes like well we should go uh
things are going great you're right on
the money my guy I did probably yeah
probably yes
um and I do love this idea too that he
can he thinks Ellie's not scared because
she shows a face of like calmness and
she jokes around she's still ready to
joke around and when they find that
daycare and she's like can we please
just stay because there's stuff to do
here yeah like uh so child like even
though she's much older than Sam she's
closer to Sam than she has to Joel yeah
so it's like having this in her life is
like so nice and we know she's lost so
much and it's so heavy I wish we had
gotten more of that Community I know
under yeah underground I would like to
see a little more about it but they had
that white board that said if you hear
this single noise run to your hiding
spots and it was like don't be loud and
all these other things and I was like oh
that sucks I I drew I almost Drew
parallels between that and like the
school shootings we have nowadays where
it's like they have to be so on edge and
on alert now where if they hear a
certain alarm hiding places to go to and
it just reminds you like the tragedy
that kids are facing and that's how bad
the Kansas City QC was right it's better
to be under Underground on our own
hiding than to even be in this like
fedris place you mentioned that last
week about L.A pot like as a woman also
in this situation a possibility of being
like assaulted you have to watch out for
like even just men yeah that are in the
area or women and
um when uh Henry said that he was like
they were raping murdering right doing
everything to everybody yeah and I was
like oh this is our first time talking
about it out loud that they are
assaulting people also with accuses yeah
not great not great stuff
um well we have lots I want to talk
about this episode we want to thank our
sponsors real fast uh in a world in our
world in the year 2023 we're fortunate
enough that we're not we don't have
these like quarter steps running around
right we'd have to worry about that we
know things are great we don't have that
awfulness happening but we do have one
awfulness happening and that's high
phone bills
thankfully there's men mobile men mobile
was the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only you order
from home and you save a ton with phone
plans starting at just 15 bucks a month
lots of your us here at new rockstars of
switchmate mobile it's great you can
keep your phone you can keep all your
contacts you have that unlimited talking
text great data high speed 5G Network
boom 15 bucks a month
it's great uh how is mint mobile able to
do this you might ask yourself well they
went online only they don't have like
the traditional retail stores that add
more cost to your phone plans they they
got rid of that and they passed the
savings right on to you like I said you
can get that unlimited talking text high
speed data delivered on the nation's
largest 5G Network use your own phone
with any mobile plan and switch easily
in minutes you can switch to Mint mobile
and get premium wireless service today
starting at just 15 bucks a month to do
that all you got to do is go to
mintmobile.com break room that's
mintmobile.com breakroom uh you switch
to that plan for 15 bucks a month and
then you get that you get it ship right
to your door for free cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month atmobile.com
break room
we also want to thank factor for
sponsoring the show today
uh we also want to thank factor for
sponsoring the show today there's
nothing worse than wrapping up a long
day at work only to go home and face
like a long night of cooking dinner I
hate it I don't want to chop up my food
I don't want to decide what to eat I
don't want to go to the grocery store
deal with all those people some people
are wearing masks some people aren't you
go to the produce section I don't know
what a ripe pineapple is supposed to
look like what do I do what do I do get
factor and not only skip that awful trip
to the grocery store but you can skip
the chopping the prepping the cleaning
up afterwards factors fresh never frozen
meals already in just two minutes and
all you have to do is heat and enjoy
from keto well Anna if you are keto and
I strongly suggest that you're not
they do have meals that are keto salary
smart vegan and veggie they're full of
protein these meals are prepared by
chefs and approved by dietitians each
meal has all the ingredients you need to
feel satisfied all day long they're not
these wimpy little heat up meals they're
good they're filling you're going to
feel great they have 34 Chef prepared
dietitian approved weekly options every
week there's always something new to try
plus you can round out your meal and
replenish your snack Supply with an
assortment of quick bites smoothies
juices and more satisfying add-ons get
factor and enjoy clean eating without
the hassle head to factormeals.com break
room 50 and use code breakroom 50 to get
50 off your first box what is that 50
off your first box all you got to do is
go to uh factorreels.com break room50
and Enter code break room 50 to get 50
off your first box Beauty
I'm applauding VA oh I do like yeah yeah
ASL plotting love it love it Anna
show isn't exactly like the video game
there were some changes in this episode
from the game well Brandon I'll tell you
some similarities and some differences
okay great so this is your warning if
not we're not going any further than the
show has covered but if you want to play
the game totally clean now's your chance
to mini spoilers click off
um so like most of these episodes uh
except episode three uh this followed a
lot of the same beats as the game
however there were definitely some uh
details that were left in left out
things that we want to talk about so we
gonna talk about those kick
all right
um so the first thing and maybe we
should have mentioned this last time I
don't know but we'll talk about it now
is that the way that they run into Henry
and Sam for the first time is different
than in the game uh in the game Joel is
like climbing through this window of an
apartment building when Henry uh comes
around with a gun like takes him by
surprise uh but Joel kicks his ass and
is like beating his face on the ground
and then Sam comes in with the gun it
only gets in with it's a whole thing uh
but they don't sneak up on them in the
middle of the night
um so that's a little bit different uh
they also never talk about in the games
that their guns weren't loaded for all
we know they absolutely we're loaded so
that's new uh in the game they weren't
originally from Pittsburgh or Kansas
City uh they were actually from Hartford
traveling with this group that decided
to enter the city in order to scavenge
uh but they were ambushed by the well in
the show now whoever was that Raiders
Hunters Hunters generic bad guys they
were ambushed uh so so that bit is new
the the part about them living in the
city and Henry having to get leukemia
medication for his brother is absolutely
new uh not only because Kathleen's
character is completely new to the show
but because Sam doesn't have leukemia in
the game
um he also isn't deaf that's that's a
new detail uh he's also in the game
about Ellie's age she Ellie says she's
14 when yes he's like me too and Henry's
like oh are you he's one close so
probably about 13. yeah and I don't know
whether this change was made in the show
because they just wanted to find the
right actor and base the agent I might
have been what like Jessica was saying
with like I think he just won the role
right actors yeah the casting was for
eight to fourteen so yeah yeah so I I'm
I am curious though if they if they
found the right actor in Bay stage off
that or if they were like we do kind of
want to go younger for this particular
character in the show who knows they
might say in the podcast we're not there
yet uh so there's also a moment in the
game where they go into a toy store the
four of them all together grouped up uh
and Sam wants to take a little
Transformer toy with him but Henry is
like nah can't do that he's a philosophy
that they only take what they need and
he's very uh stingent about that but
Ellie sneaks it into her backpack and
then later gives it to him which is a
very heartfelt moment yeah
um the order that they exit the city is
is a little bit different uh they they
kind of escape and then they're climbing
a truck and uh Ellie and Joel help Henry
and Sam get up on the truck and they
managed to get Ellie up but when the the
Raiders are coming they're like Joe we
don't know if we can help you we've got
a piece out now he's like what and jumps
back down so they kind of leave him for
Dead uh the Raiders are chasing Joel and
Ellie they get to a bridge a broken
bridge and Ellie's like we gotta jump
even though she can't swim and so they
jump down and then we have like a is
Joel gonna die is Ellie gonna die kind
of floating moment and then uh Henry and
Sam end up saving them pulling them to
Shore and uh that's when they team up
again so that's a little different too
uh regarding the tunnels we spend a lot
more time which I wish we did in the
show too we spent a lot more time in
that underground Community we learned
through a series of letters they're
they're sort of like daily lives it's
very like it's very sad they make jokes
to each other and like it's very
heartfelt you can see how it was slowly
getting worse yeah yeah I guess things
are running out
um we learned from a letter that uh
someone has accidentally left the door
one of the doors open like one time and
a bunch of infected get in and they all
get separated and then we come across a
very grisly scene that they left out of
the show where uh we basically learned
from a letter that one dude and I think
three kids was this little group of kids
who are under a tarp uh he leaves in a
letter like we can hear we're trapped in
here we can hear the infected trying to
get in I'll make sure that they don't
suffer as they go and so that's very
dark stuff it's very tough but but I I
just think it's so um meaningful like
learning about this little Community
down here and how they function and it
really like humanized them I felt I felt
that was a little missing but hey uh one
reference that I'm sure a lot of the
gamers were thrilled about and was the
reference to ish uh ish in the game for
those who haven't played it her dude
just didn't look at the letters uh he
was kind of a comedic relief like we
learned a lot about him uh he's part of
that underground community and I think a
lot of people were hoping to get him in
the show like
Odyssey like an ish yeah and I almost
thought that old man with a gun
yeah stop shooting at us yeah his name
was Anthony God bless ish
um but you know we got a little nod so
that's kind of cute uh in the game
there's a moment where Henry and Ellie
get separated from Joel and Sam and the
two father not father figures have a kid
swap which is also a new show on TLC uh
and they get closer because of that
right uh we do have that neighborhood
scene where the sniper is shooting at
them but he's not working with Kathleen
because Helen's dog Emily doesn't exist
uh instead he's a younger guy who Joel
gets in there and he ambushes him they
gave him they can't see them plays out
and uh they do have that moment where um
Joel is sniping trying to defend
everyone uh in the game you're kind of
Defending everyone equally in the show I
felt like they really put an emphasis
that Joel is only going to protect Ellie
first and foremost I also hated that
part of the game
it's a stressful part of the game yeah
uh and instead of a horde of a bunch of
infected coming out from the ground it's
just three little injections and then
each tackle one of them while Joel has
to watch uh and that is where Sam gets
bit
um so there's no bloater there's no it's
only three infect instead of a giant
underground rally but that moment of
Joel sniping is very similar uh this
water doesn't throw spores at all um
which makes sense because the creators
have already said they're not really
doing the Spore thing uh it almost I
thought they were going to go with the
shambler route where he hugs them and
explodes but uh didn't you know you know
ripped his head off
fully effective in killing someone you
know what can you do uh and in the game
finally Ellie and Sam do have a moment
where they talk about ending up alone
and being afraid of that
um this conversation is obviously a lot
more extended in the game because it
takes some time to ride on that magic
pad in the show it's good tension though
as you're waiting to see what each
person is riding with you that's very
true
um but they they have that conversation
where he says he's afraid he's like do
you think they're trapped in their
bodies they have a conversation about
like whether or not they go to heaven
and if Ellie believes that or not and
she's like I some days I do sometimes I
don't
um all fungus goes to heaven as long as
goes to heaven the sequel of the tree
cool they didn't make a sequel to all
that was good yeah all cats go to hell
this is blasphemy against cats I won't
have it
um and Ellie doesn't sleep in the same
room as uh Sam which would make sense
because if he's not dead she didn't know
in the game they would have they would
have uh he would have immediately
attacked her so it's basically just she
wakes up she's like where's Sam Henry's
like I let him sleep in and goes she
goes check on him and the attack
uh so because of the uh not because of
this there's also no uh burial moment or
I'm sorry note that we get at the end
it's just a cold cold time jump to the
fall
yeah I think all the changes made great
made a lot of sense I love tying
Kathleen into what's happened in the
show the way they tied Kathleen into
this moment in the game and Henry and
Sam all being tied together in that
storyline it was great I really like to
wrap how it wrapped up uh kill counts
for this episode this was a tough one a
lot going on in this episode all right
we the people is what I'm calling the uh
the people who overtook uh fedra uh
Kathleen's people uh because they were
we the people on the trucks a lot so I'm
gonna call them we the people she also
said haven't you Kansas City's free now
that was one of a very dark moment from
her so they killed about 30 people
Federal people I saw them kill including
the informants and stuff there's about
almost 20 kids sitting in that room
obviously they killed a lot more but
that's what I saw on screen and then
when the horde's coming on the ground to
kill about 25 infected again tough to
tell a lot of running around a lot of
extras just running back and forth in
the background but that's what I could
see Joel does pretty well this episode
he kills three people uh three actual
people and then he kills like nine
infected I give him three because he
shoots the woman driving the truck and
then the truck explodes there's another
guy in the passenger seat so I count
that to Joel that's math that's math
if he didn't shoot her he wouldn't die
there you go and Joel Snipes about nine
infected from what I can tell uh we hear
some more shots but we don't see a body
drop so I don't know he misses a bunch
too yeah
uh plus his hand still hurts
um Ellie kills one infected gets a
little knife uh and and then the the
second one these are the infected
attacking Henry and Sam the second one
she nice and Joel finishes off so she
gets the assist for that one the
infected themselves they get at least
20. at least 20 of those we the people
they killed it Mofo's running around uh
they did a great the bloat are getting
two good ones that we see on screen
really great one and the little girl
getting Kathleen great stuff Henry gets
two no more talk about that uh now we'll
get into some full spoiler talk so we
can talk about game two talk about
everything we know about the storyline
so full spoilers go away if you don't
want to hear anything else let's talk
about these bloater changes okay this
blow so in the game uh specifically Last
of Us Part Two we also have shamblers
who explode spores uh in a slightly
different way they burst from their dead
bodies versus a bloater who throws like
grenades of Spore balls right uh which
is something we haven't seen in the show
and as you pointed out like Craig Mason
is kind of Neil druckman have kind of
indicated they don't want to do spores
because it doesn't really make sense I
think they could be lying I think we
could see that coming to play later I
like that Pedro Pascal was like a
Mandalorian I can't wear a mask and then
this is like actually you know what I'll
wear I should wear a mask uh so we'll
see if the sports come into it but yeah
a little bit of a bloater change there
uh uh Ellie does make those comments
like earlier on uh in episode two uh
when they're walking through the Boston
area and she's like I heard there's you
know infected that throws spores and
blah blah blah and Tess and Joel kind of
laugh it off
uh but maybe they've just never seen it
you know they only know what they know
or maybe it's just a wives tale maybe
it's just an old wife because Ellie knew
about the clickers and those turned out
to be true obviously uh but yeah we
don't know if they'll get into shamblers
at all are they gonna say that for
season two is that thing they'll just do
away with completely I don't know I
don't know uh Ellie Ellie trying to save
Sam here uh you know I obviously she
fails at saving Riley which is something
we're going to learn more about as the
season goes on she's failed at saving
Sam right her blood didn't work there uh
she'll watch as she can't save Joel in
season two of the show assuming they
follow the game stuff uh her parallel to
like kind of she's very parallel to like
Kathleen in a lot of ways right Kathleen
is a person who who loves her brother
Michael is very different from her
brother Michael in that like she's
willing to do the dirty stuff get the
Revenge she's willing to tear up this
whole town after taking out federal her
number one goal is to get Henry and Sam
despite what her advisors you know
Perry's saying to her like we shouldn't
be wasting these resources Resource
Management manage them uh we shouldn't
be wasting this but this is her thing
she's so driven by Revenge here right
really no a Kathleen but Ali will be
driven by revenge in part two right yes
yeah so they it's kind of an interesting
parallel because Kathleen's a totally
new character uh so we're gonna kind of
see how we turn into Kathleen in a lot
of ways assuming like season two of this
show follows like uh The Last of Us Part
Two I think we could see a lot of
similarity uh similarity there right I
think the whole conversation revolving
around Kathleen not seeing it Justified
that Henry tried to say like would rat
out the entire group just trying to save
one kid I think that's way more relevant
of a comparison that we're gonna get at
the end of the season where the question
is is one kid's life worth the entirety
of humanity right um I was definitely
seeing parallels there that's a great
Point yeah and when we get to the finale
of the season right uh and the effects
of what happens in that finale are gonna
mess with Ellie for a long time because
she's gonna think that she's not a cure
right she sees it plays out in this
episode and then what happens in the
finale you know she'll be told like ah
no they couldn't fix you or whatever
like it didn't work right and so she's
gonna go on thinking she's not a cure
but maybe she is you know does she
possibly could be and instead she's
going to go on this like Revenge Mission
uh and we'll even see a little bit of
that play out in this season with like
the cannibals right when she hears that
like oh they're coming to get us or
they're they're looking for us like and
she's gonna have to turn on she's going
to find a community she's gonna think
it's great and then learn that it's not
so great one other quick thing like uh
Joel in this episode hears you know from
Henry like you were someone's father
right uh now this could be setting up
when Joel finally finds Tommy he's gonna
if they follow the game that they've
we've seen they've done so far in a lot
of ways Joel's gonna try and pass Ellie
off to Tommy uh and like walk away from
the situation Ellie's gonna hear that be
pissed off maybe run away if they follow
all that stuff we'll have to see but
it's kind of setting that up right like
a Tommy next episode is going to be like
no you should like take care of her like
she should stay with you John she'll be
like no I don't want to be anyone's
father anymore but in the end he's gonna
have to be her father like he's gonna
have to take care of her uh it's gonna
be an important thing so it's like
Henry's got telling him like no you are
you're someone's father you were
someone's father and you currently are
someone's father you're Ellie's father
the bond is being cemented one episode
yeah Ellie ends up telling y'all like
I'm not your daughter in the game she's
like I'm not your daughter and Joel says
you're goddamn right you're not like
we've seen them get closer together and
it's so nice to see that but we know
from storytelling like they're gonna
have to go to a point where they're far
apart again uh and then really really
come back together stronger than ever
before and it's going to be so hard to
see that play out I can't wait I can
wait I can't just give me like three
happy episodes in a row please there's a
person without a dad I love watching but
that's fail that is it for the last
episode of the break room we'll be back
next week to discuss episode six but we
also do the show every day live at 3 P.M
are you guys talking about all the nerdy
stuff that you guys love and need to
know and on Sunday we'll be going live
right after the Super Bowl oh the game I
don't know what that is to talk about
all the wild trailers we're gonna uh
we're expected to see and get and we're
so excited about it follow me at Lulu
underscore Clemens follow Brandon at
grin and Barrick follow Anna it's Anna
vanston subscribe to the break from
wherever you get your podcast and we'll
see you guys on Sunday thanks for
watching enjoy and survive it's a bad
slogan
[Music]